What to get me for my birthday.
So it's my birthday on May 20th.
It's also Kristina's birthday.
We have the same birthday.
She's my video editor.
Does a lot of this stuff.
Over the years I've gone from wanting products
To wanting experiences
To wanting impact.
And so, when I was younger I wanted stuff.  I wanted toys.  Right.  I wanted new shoes or new computer
Or new clothes.  Whatever it was.
As I got older it became less and less important
One, I can go out and get whatever I needed and I would just buy it
if I wanted it.
There was nothing on my list that "I wish I could go and buy this thing."
Two, I've been getting rid of stuff.
Like I have two much stuff
People are sending me stuff
It's a good problem to have I guess.  But I want to pair down.
I don't need as much stuff anymore to be happy.
So I don't want people to send me
"stuff" as a birthday present.
I moved to experiences.  And experiences is like
Let's go enjoy a baseball game together.
Or on a vacation.
Or let's learn how to snowboard.
Give me a certificate for the winter.  We'll go snowboarding.
And I still like that stuff.  I still appreciate it.
Still like it more than products.
Again, like if I wanted to go do something I could go do it.
I don't like being away from Toronto for too long.  There's too much important stuff I'm doing here.
There's no new experience I am dying to try out
If I was, I would just go out and do it.
Well what I am moving more and more towards is impact.
Like the thing that gets me excited
is knowing that I am helping somebody
Like, I am having a meaning impact in their life somehow
So earlier this week Alex asked me "What can I get you for your birthday?"
It's coming up.  Tell me what you want. I'm a guy
You're a guy.  You don't have to beat around the bush.  Just tell me what you want.
I'll go out and buy it.
I said "Alex.  I don't need anything.  Don't buy me anything.  The biggest thing you could do is
Do something that's on your bucket list.
Do something that you're afraid of.
Or just been putting off for too long.
Go out and do that
and let me birthday be the excuse
for you to go out and do it
So he's been looking into skydiving.
Evan talking to Alex: "Did you book it?"
Alex:  Ye!  I did book it
Evan to Alex: Tandem right?  You're going to be strapped.
So the biggest thing you guys could get me.  If you are looking to do something.
Is I would love for you too, look at your list.
Of things that you really want to do.
Something that's on your bucket list.
Something that you are afraid of doing.
And just do it!
Let this be the excuse to actually go out and do it
Don't wait five years for it to happen
Take one thing, cross it off and do it.
And tell me what it is.
Even if you haven't done it yet.
Take an action to plan to do it.
Leave it in the comments below.
That would really make
my birthday super special
Please, please, please, take action!
I want to have some impact beyond what I am already doing
So thank you guys so much.  You have been an insane
source of
joy for the past year
I'm looking forward to another
10, 20, 30, 40, 50 years of doing this!
Continue to BELIEVE!
And I'll see you soon!